hello my name is Natasha I am a reporter
for Russian television here to cover
American culture today I talk to classic
American persons hello I am here with
classic American comedian Maria Bamford
if apocalypse happens how will you help
I know I'm the first one who will eat
all the chocolate if we're in a rubber
raft like I cannot be trusted I want to
say I can be a meat shield thrown in
front of a shark or what have you it is
very selfless well they just think I'm
realistic of what I'm capable and also
who wants to be around once apocalypse
Americans love paying a lot of money for
cheap things like eggs and pizza how do
you throw your money away I spent seven
dollars on a coffee today beans and
wallet you can to a certain point where
you for dirty being yeah it's like black
beans and water
the Americans like food trucks San
Francisco likes food trucks alive see
I'm confused by food trucks because I
thought if there is a man in a van
giving us food you don't go inside
they're not like offering lollipops okay
but if they are long regularly from
that's a sign that's no good but if it's
like a wet hot dog or something that's
okay and especially if it's twenty
dollars you know that it's good the more
expensive the better a more expensive
the less the predator yes you have
traveled all across the US performing
stand-up and what are you running from
definitely from a fear that I don't
exist
you've got to keep traveling to see that
people still know that you are alive and
then merge merge or the marquee exchange
of merge with other comics it's like a
barter
yeah as a partisan in my apartment I
have seven DVDs that I stack up one on
top of another just to show I have well
what music are they pornographic oh nice
so there is music but I would say people
are not maybe off-key
what about festivals do love it's a good
value for money you come in you pay one
price you can see so many different acts
at what festivals is like the Walmart of
entertainment I like to think that
people just go because everyone else is
going it's like that famous phrase right
if your friend jump off a bridge you
don't embarrass yourself jump off that
bridge first yeah that's that's it you
have a Golden Gate Bridge here perfect
for jumping you heard it here first
they're going to jump out the Golden
Gate Bridge with your show Joe joy Joel
Joel joy Club is a celebration of Asian
talents yes a government okay with you
starting race whore
I don't think they love it okay they've
accepted it do you worry though you put
them all together in one room it's like
no I didn't actually think that it would
be a trap until just now thank you so
much thank you so much Joel thank you
thank you so much you can we get them a
napkin because I might have Colts or
something
[Music]